KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Hey, Martin, did
you see that Livestream
from the nature reserve?
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Katie.
Yeah, I'm watching it now.
It looks like a Django
pony had wandered
into unicorn territory.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Geez,
I hope they get along OK.
MARTIN OMANDER: Here's hoping.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Alex is an engineer
at Vivid, a digital agency
that creates websites
for their clients using Django.
Django is a web framework
written in Python
that handles serving
web pages for you.
You define data models
as Python objects,
and Django simplifies
communicating these
to a database.
Vivid's client websites,
like agate construction,
currently runs on servers
in Vivid's office.
But the company is
moving to The Cloud.
Alex looked at running their
existing client websites
on virtual machines,
but that would require
a fair amount of ops work.
Alex wonders, can
they serverless?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Yeah, they can.
Cloud Run is a managed
serverless platform, where
each server run stateless.
No data is stored on
the servers itself.
But Cloud Run can
connect to state
for backing services,
databases, APIs, and the like.
Web frameworks that rely
on databases like Django
can run in a serverless setup
with some configuration.
The general steps
described in this video
can be used for not only
Django, but any other content
management system
that uses Django,
such as Wagtail and Django CMS.
We've created code labs that
walk you through everything
described in this video.
They're linked in the
description below.
Any Django site can be built
into a container image.
This image can be deployed
as a Cloud Run service,
but that just handles
the code part.
Django also needs
a database to store
relational data and a place to
store media and static assets.
These two backing
services need to be
provisioned and
accessible by the service.
MARTIN OMANDER: First,
let's talk data.
Django supports many
relational databases,
including PostgreSOL and MySQL.
Alex can use Cloud SQL, a
managed database service,
that supports both PostgreSOL
and MySQL, and even MS SQL.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: When Alex
first deploys their Cloud Run
service, they'll need to
set the add SQL instance
parameter, linking their Cloud
Run service with their Cloud
SQL database.
This allows the
service in the database
to communicate over
an automatically
encrypted connection.
Django will also need
connection settings.
Not just the instance hostname,
but also the database username
and password.
Alex can store these credentials
using Secret Manager,
retrieving them at runtime.
From here, everything
is set up to run
Django's migrate command.
MARTIN OMANDER: Secondly,
media and static assets.
Alex can configure
their new Django app
to use a Google Cloud Storage
bucket to store these files.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Cloud storage can
be configured as a custom
storage backend in Django using
the Django storages package.
Alex just needs to
install the package
and edit their settings.py to
use this new storage backend
and point to their new
Cloud Storage bucket.
From here, everything is set
up to run Django's collect
static command.
MARTIN OMANDER: This
all seems great.
But about those Django commands.
Where do you actually run those?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well, this
is the question, Martin.
Cloud Run focuses on
serving containers,
and doesn't provide a way to
run a one-off shell command
against a running service.
What Alex can do is
run these commands
as part of their continuous
integration process
using Google Cloud Build.
In their Cloud
Build config, they
can add a new step called
migrate between their built
step and their deploy step.
This migrate step uses the
App Engine exec wrapper,
which allows commands to
be run against a database
during a Cloud Build job.
Additionally, they
can configure this job
to be automatically run
anytime the agate code is
updated in source control
using Cloud Build triggers.
If an automated process doesn't
work for Alex's migration
strategy, they can run their
migration commands manually
with help from Cloud SQL proxy.
We've described this method in
more detail in our blog post.
MARTIN OMANDER: By connecting
these manager's services
together, Alex is able to host
their websites in the cloud.
These services automatically
scale up and down
as their load changes
throughout the day,
without having to pay a fixed
price for a virtual server.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Details
for everything mentioned
in this video,
including the code labs,
are linked in the description.
So how are the herd doing?
MARTIN OMANDER: It looks like
they're going along great.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yay.
[MUSIC PLAYING]